bonjour sylvia saïd suta et bienvenue
dans cet autre cas dit bonjour bonjour à
tous et bonne reprise à tous les
enseignants et enseignantes à l'école
aujourd'hui oui c'est le jour j les huit
cent soixante mille enseignants de
france dont celles et ceux de martinique
font leur pré rentrée ce lundi 31 août
alors on le sait dans un contexte très
particulier vous n'avez pas chômé vous
même s'il ya side soutane durant ces
grandes vacances
alors en quoi a consisté votre mission
en tant que conseillère exécutive
territoriales en charge de l'éducation
des affaires scolaires en quoi a
consisté votre mission avouée à la ctn
afin de préparer cette rentrée scolaire
donc inédite qui parce qu'elle est
marquée du sceau de l'épidémie de covin
voilà c'était vraiment d'essayer de
trouver toutes les solutions pour que
les établissements soient secure au
niveau centre de la santé donc sanitaire
donc beaucoup de travail concernant leur
âge ou de points d'eau dans les
établissements scolaires d'auge
supplémentaires pour permettre aux
enfants de se laver les mains dans les
bonnes conditions de travail et aussi
sur tous les dossiers des abysses temps
scolaire qui ont besoin de plus de fonds
plus d'argent parce que même si l'année
dernière on est resté longtemps fermé
mais on voit bien qu'on a une
augmentation en puissance des besoins en
savons gels hydroalcooliques en blouse
en masques etc
donc il a fallu faire le point sur tout
ça et oui on va y revenir et notamment
pour évaluer peut-être ce que ça coûte
s'il vient sur coup mais entre temps
entre le moment où vous avez commencé à
préparer dès la fin de l'année scolaire
précédente finalement et maintenant la
martinique a été décrétée là il ya
quelques jours à peine par le
gouvernement comme étant une des zones
rouges de du territoire français
s'agissant de la propagation de du virus
de ce coronavirus alors est-ce que cela
change quelque chose finalement
par rapport à votre dispositif tel que
ben vous l'aviez pensé jusque là jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine dernière c'est ça
aujourd'hui concernant le protocole
sanitaire qui a été déployée par le
ministère de l'éducation nationale on
est en mesure de recommencer
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas à l'abri d'un
de confinement d'école comme ça se passe
à la réunion mais moi j'ai envie d'y
croire et j'ai envie de dire que les
forces vives qui sont en martinique
mettrons tout en oeuvre pour faire en
sorte que la rentrée puis se passer dans
les meilleures conditions
maintenant ça ne dépend pas que de nous
le préfet peut prendre les décisions
effectivement qui s'imposerait sida
vente
on avait une augmentation des cales en
réanimation aujourd'hui nous n'avons que
trois personnes s'est bien passé
beaucoup déjà pour les trois personnes
qui sont mes trois personnes en
réanimation donc c'est surtout cette
alerte là qu'il nous faut avoir dans une
île
parce que autant france hexagonale on
peut envoyer les gens dans d'autres
hôpitaux en martinique non seulement on
reçoit pour nous mêmes mais aussi pour
l'art et la martinique et la guyane et
la guadeloupe
donc c'est cet indicateur mon avis qui
est important mais il faut vraiment
qu'on reparte parce que le mois de mai
deux mois de juin ont permis justement
de déployer ces protocoles sanitaires
ses sens de circulation que le chef
d'établissement se sont évertués à faire
pendant le mois de mai le mois de juin
les protocoles les gestes barrière la
formation des agents la formation des
professeurs et donc j'ai envie de dire
qu'il faut y aller parce que c'est un
enjeu majeur l'éducation c'est un enjeu
majeur
je crois que c'est même l'enjeu le plus
important d'une société alors votre
dispositif est ce qu'il est comment
dirais-je figé là au moment où on parle
ou est ce que c'est un dispositif par la
force des choses qui doit être souple et
que qui sera adapté un petit peu au jour
le jour
en sachant que de toute façon la matière
le risque zéro n'existe pas exactement
face et c'est quelque chose qui fâche je
crois vraiment que le mot c'est
l'adaptation
il faudra qu'on s'adapte alors on est
assez fort martine pour s'adapter on
s'est adapté à beaucoup on est dans
l'histoire beaucoup de situations
difficiles
on s'en est toujours sorti donc j'ai
envie de dire qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment qu'on travaille dans
l'adaptation et surtout dans le retour
des choses c'est à dire que s'il ya un
problème
à chaque problème une solution donc
trouver en fonction du goût du de
l'endroit où ça se fait et puis que
peut-être que que les solutions trouvées
puis servir à d'autres donc voilà alors
s'agissant des masques des savons et
autres gels hydroalcooliques la virucide
comment ça se passe et c'est à la charge
de qui finalement cette affaire alors
c'est à la charge de ne tout c'est de
nous tout c'est à dire que c'est
l'argent de la collectivité dont qui
valent pour laquelle on va donner des
subventions donne des deux pins
différencions les dotations de
subvention de dotation d'équipement et
de fonctionnement aux établissements
donc c'est avec ces dotations que les
chefs d'établissement achète le gel
hydroalcoolique achète le savons les
masques par contre sont directement
donné par la collectivité territoriale
de martinique pour nos agents avec un
kit agents à gel hydroalcoolique masque
pour pour toute la période pour les
agents les agents le pour lutter le
ministère de l'éducation nationale donne
pour les opc et l'équipe d'encadrement
et alors il ya trois jours monsieur le
ministre a donc déclaré que les masques
serait à la charge des parents donc
lorsque je me suis entretenu avec eux
mêmes et pour leurs enfants qui sont à
l'école voilà les élèves qui sont encore
devrait porter des masses depuis la
sixième lorsque moi j'ai entendu ça j'en
ai un peu discuté avec mes homologues de
france hexagonale avec qui on a des
réunions souvent et je me suis dit
peut-être que même si il est important
qu'on responsabilise les gens nuisant
ils ont des enfants il faut les protéger
c'est du le rôle du parent de lui donner
à manger de le protéger
on connaît aussi la situation économique
en martinique et à mon avis va falloir
que nous ctm on puisse offrir en tout
cas donné peut-être moi j'avais pensé à
30% de l'effectif d'un établissement
scolaire en stop stratégique de masque
parce que imaginez un enfant le parent
peut-être des difficultés il a peut-être
trois quatre enfants il n'a peut-être
pas suffisamment de moyens à ce moment
là il va prendre un masque va laisser
l'image toute la semaine à l'enfant et
ça n'a pas marché ça ne protégera
personne donc les enseignants et
enseignantes serait peut-être très
clairvoyant et pourrait changer le
masque enfin voilà donc sans prendre si
vous voulez la responsabilité qui est dû
aux parents c'est le parent qui doit
s'occuper de son enfant c'est le premier
devoir d'un parent quand il m'a un
enfant sur la terre je le dis toujours
mais malgré tout on connaît quelques
situations difficiles et donc il faut
les autres maillons douala il faut que
nous soyons là à côté
pour les hommes c'est le projet que je
nourris puisque ces trois jours
seulement qu'on a appris cette
organisation oui comme quoi il on voit
bien qu'il faut s'adapter alors du coup
combien combien il en coûte enfin ce que
vous avez déjà évalué le surcoût en
termes de fourniture de masques
notamment donc pour les personnels
techniques et administratifs
ben oui forcément alors vous avez parlé
de subventions oui le dotation de
dotation aux établissements neufs ou
bien il faut bien les htc masqué tu te
fasses bien les commandes et donc il ya
un coût supplémentaire c'est ça alors la
collectivité sans compter par exemple
que les os je ne sais pas pourquoi les
points supplémentaires même si beaucoup
d'entreprises
vous les jouez le jeu vous savez on aime
bien martinique dire un peu tout et son
contraire il ya des éphèbes
établissements qu'ils disent oui mon n'a
pas encore nos nos points d'eau dans
l'établissement ce n'est pas normal oui
mais sauf que les entreprises elles ont
beaucoup souffert pendant le temps de
confinement est aujourd'hui quand elle
cherche des au jeu supplémentaire pour
mettre dans les établissements scolaires
c'est en rupture de stock donc on est
sur une île il faut attendre que ça
vienne et donc on s'est engagé auprès
des chefs d'établissement
tout n'est pas encore complet de ce bout
là il reste encore des stars du genre à
équiper des anneaux ses 720 mille euros
qu'on a prévu pour cette enveloppe là et
donc c'est en cours il ya beaucoup
d'établissements qui ont déjà le point
d'eau mais par exemple il ya un exemple
on a 70 points d'eau qui arrivent là
demain après demain le mercredi 2 et qui
seront posées au fur et à mesure on peut
pas tirer sans d'une roche donc on est
obligé de faire avec ça en corse et une
adaptabilité et je demande aux usagers
ou usagère de prendre un peu patience
les choses se feront
voilà alors il ya des syndicats qui
demandent que les masques soit fournie
gratuitement à tous les collégiens aux
lycéens
alors vous avez déjà un petit peu
répondu partiellement vous ai dit
évidemment le gouvernement de toute
façon a dit que c'est la responsabilité
des parents avant tout mais on peut les
accompagner
et donc là dessus c'est saignant
inenvisageable comme je vous dis c'est
moi j'ai envie de j'ai envie de vous
dire que le rôle du parent c'est de
protéger son enfant
donc il faut trouver des solutions alors
c'est vrai que les masques vont ont
diminué un moment et la boîte de 50
masques étaient 50 euros aujourd'hui on
est à 29 euros j'espère que ça va encore
descendre et il faut quand même intégré
que personne n'a voulu ce virus c'est
qu'il faut faire avec
donc il faut il faut que la que la
société puisse se jouer la solidarité
sans faire entrer les gens dans
l'assistanat donc fusion dans les
masques pour tous ça veut dire qu'il ya
des gens qui ont des masses qui ont
prévu d'ailleurs très très normalement
de données de masquer leurs enfants on
aura un surplus inutile donc il faut
savoir gérer avec le fonds social qui a
existants les établissements scolaires
avec l'aide de la collectivité qui met
des acteurs en fonction de situations de
chacun des foyers aussi parce qu elle a
eu lieu il ya une chose que j'ai que
j'ai fait et je suis très fier avec les
élus de la cmc qu'on a voté 4 millions
d'euros pour parce que
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide 1 est
donc cette histoire de fracture
numérique que nous avons vécu en
martinique très particulièrement pendant
cette ce confinement m'a fait imaginer
un projet qui a été actée donc de 15
millions d'euros où nous allons avant
les vacances de noël donc entre
toussaint et noël donné une tablette à
tous les élèves qui rentrent en sixième
qui sont en 6e est un ordinateur
portable à tous les élèves qui rentrent
en seconde
sur un plan plus rire tous les cinq ans
et tout le monde dans le lycée le lycée
c'est tellement logique des migrants
seconde qui attendait au cul et pourquoi
parce que justement là on aurait pu dire
oui il faut faire en fonction des gens
qui ont qui ont pas sauf qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'il ya des gens qui ont
parfois un ordinateur et qui ont par
contre à trois enfants et quand les
cours se font il manquait les
ordinateurs dont chaque élève de 6e aura
et un plan pluriannuel qui permet chaque
année d'avoir un ordinateur qui montent
jusqu en troisième une tablette et un
porte un portable du monde jusqu'en
terminale s et des mises à disposition
pour tout le monde ça c'est une grande
avancée je suis très contente que les
élus aient voté ça en quelques mots sur
le transport le transport scolaire les
conditions de transport enfin pour
monter circuler dans les bus
et puis est-ce que tout est opérationnel
c'est à dire quoi la veille 2 alors
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai eu des
petites vacances ils sont a
effectivement des réunions avec martine
transport qui vraiment nous a permis de
dire que c'était tout était en capacité
d'accueil des élèves alors le protocole
a été allégé ce qui fait qu'il n'ya plus
de distanciation dans le cas donc toutes
les places peuvent être utilisés mais
martin transports a prévu de toute façon
le scénario si d'aventuré on devait
réduire encore les places dans le bus
donc tout est opérationnel les les
inscriptions se font sur marty que
transporte sur la plateforme donc je
pense que les choses se passeront au
vieux il ya des chantiers en cours dans
des bâtiments des lycées qui sont
notamment le sait ben yahia sainte marie
mai mais ya pas que ça c'est peut-être
le plus le plus emblématique alors où on
en est alors plus un chantier de 15
millions d'euros je l' ai voulu parce
que c'était un an dans
un endroit dangereux pour les élèves
lorsqu'il était au bourg de sainte marie
aujourd'hui on est en phase d'achèvement
on espère je touche le bois qui est dans
votre studio on espère que la partir du
11 septembre les élèves du lycée nord
atlantique vont intégrer leurs
établissements scolaires
c'est ce que nous souhaitons tous sont
où tout est fait pour ça et que les
élèves du collège fassent leur rentrée à
partir de demain au collège emmanuel
salle de sainte marie on a fait beaucoup
de travaux également pour pouvoir
accueillir ces élèves là en rajoutant
des toilettes supplémentaires des salles
de classe et on espère qu'à la toussaint
après la toussaint qui puisse intégrer
le site de charpentier donc ces moments
un challenge durrrr les entreprises
jouent le jeu pleinement nos agents
aussi je les en remercie parce qu'ils
sont d'arrache-pied sur ce chantier
et quand ce sera fait moi je pousse un
ouf de soulagement parce que je veux
dire qu'on aura pu mettre nos enfants de
sainte marie en sécurité alors il nous
reste peu de temps ci dessous tonnes
juste pour signaler quand même que la
ctm a relancé comment dirais-je cordées
de la réussite vous savez puisqu'il ya
une date limite de dépôt des dossiers
qui est fixé là au 30 novembre
donc faut en dire quelques mots parce
que vous dites qu à travers ce
dispositif vous favoriser l'accès aux
grandes écoles pour une plus grande
équité sociale pouvait rappeler
rapidement conventions d'éducation
prioritaire et des cordées de la
réussite a donc ça permet en fait à des
élèves qui parfois n'auraient pas la
possibilité d'accéder aux grandes écoles
de se mettre en situation avant la
terminale de donc d'être boosté pendant
les vallées petites vacances et même
pendant le temps scolaire pour avoir une
manière de de travail et donc on leur
donne beaucoup d'outils pour travailler
pour envisager justement c'est entrer
dans les grandes écoles donc c'est une
préparation si vous voulez qu'ils se
font au lycée de la jetée qui se fait
dans d'autres établissements et c'est un
plus parce que ça monte ça fonctionne
très bien avec des professeurs
d'université qui interviennent et qui
donne si vous voulez le la manière de
faire la date de dépôt des dossiers donc
fixé au 30 novembre prochain juste
vraiment qu'elle en 30 secondes
oui c'est une année scolaire qui
correspond aussi plus singulièrement
pour vous à une année électorale en mars
mais il y aura des élections vous voulez
rempiler
avait déjà pris votre décision alors oui
un moment je me pose la question mais là
ça y est c'est bon on rempile et non
seulement rempile mais moi je suis prête
à offrir un beau projet pour la
martinique j'ai envie qu'on y aille
qu'on soit d'aider des gens en
avant-garde et qu'on joue pleinement le
rôle avec toutes les dotations d'europe
et qu'on y aille oui je suis nous sommes
prêts nous sommes prêts à y voilà merci
sylvia side soutane bonne journée à tous
et bonne journée à tous